oh come here
don't yet not yet not yet oh he's so
excited to go today is the day that
Maddie gets the snip I'm just getting
ready for my day and Jenna's dropping
him off going to be a good boy today
with your snips near see you bye bye
here's the car you think I'm beautiful
honey I'm very very sorry to do this
deal I just hold on we're going home you
know who said that Drake said that hey
guys so this is what I did today my
sister took Maddie to the vet and this
is why I couldn't go because I did a
really crazy shoot today's I'm waiting
to get in the shower shower off this
blood and then I'm going home to see my
baby boy Johnson sending me pictures all
day of his little surgery and it breaks
my heart cuz this is probably what he
looked like earlier is mommy here
mommy's here
oh please don't jump she's gonna come
another door ah is that mommy
Oh careful careful oh god please don't
jump oh gosh oh oh there's our home boy
so I just got back from the shoot and I
had to shower because I was absolutely
on a percent covered in fake blood but
our little baby is here I just gave him
a few little snacks know how they do
enjoy he's good he's just been sleeping
all day
oh and running into walls all this so
sad yes interferes when do his other
columns come in they should come in
tomorrow I got a couple different
options oh look at you sweet man
she'll give him like a little snack you
think he's like what you guys doing to
me look at his little peg leg oh I took
the bandage off I was like wow look how
million EGIS he's so tiny you got kinda
late it is so little Oh what are our
instructions 14 days yeah I told you
working me oh honey no no no no
Oh community when he like ten minutes
after he had a spell he was just like
just says mommy look at this new money
to meet him he doesn't know how to sit
I was happening baby what are you doing
amazing put his foot in the water
Oh Hani he's so hungry
yeah little foot is still on today
before we left for the shoot I said
goodbye name because I would like what
if something happened I never see him
again it was like the saddest thing I
know I had a voicemail cuz I like my
phones on file and I was like terrified
to listen to the voicemail they just
said it was an attitude very good nose
like oh good eye and I called her back
immediately I need to be a bigger it is
our dog is so big this isn't so sure you
know no this is your favorite you look
more at it oh no don't do that oh my
goodness who do you think you are bud
stay oh my god you're making a mess it's
everywhere right Maddie tell everybody
thank you for the well wishes thank you
guys so much for watching it this was a
quick vlog but a lot of you guys are
asking about Maddie and he's doing very
well and thanks to Jennifer gonna take
him today to my video I was so upset
that I had to shoot today but I couldn't
cancel it and it seriously came up last
minute and we couldn't change a surgery
okay Howie had a good time oh boy good
thing good thing you've got two moms you
got a new computer look at you did a
panga cone nobody why Maddie I love you
baby boy oh I was so worried
see you guys later you can call my phone
I'm freaking
listen to tunes on my road trip